so first of all
big fan of thrillers horror films i
loved torn hearts because you are so
good in this movie you're like a puppet
master you just have to say certain
things and people do bad things
yeah seems to be yes yeah but i will say
you in a shotgun is scary
um how much fun did you have with this
role so much fun i had never done um
a horror movie
so i was really excited to
to do that and
you know to play a country western star
gone a little whack
was very enticing and even before i read
the script i thought oh yeah this would
be great and then i got to sing in it
and
i got to
you know
i found her very vulnerable and scary at
the same time
i completely agree like a part of you
has empathy but then of course she does
some pretty wild things that you can't
forgive so it was really really great
kind of watching the different um i
don't know i guess just kind of levels
of this character what was it like for
you getting to sing
um well that's always fun for me and it
was great that the girls were good
singers
and um
so yeah i love you know i'm i come from
a music background so i i really i
really like it when i get to sing and it
makes sense for the character to sing
you know a lot of times i'm asked to
sing in a role that's like no she
wouldn't sing
but this one you know this is definitely
her genre so that was really exciting
amazing has anybody in your family seen
you in this role yet
no
trailer right so what's the reaction you
get from your family just because i've
never seen a role like this before yeah
no they're excited everybody's excited
i'm i'm excited i just i just i had so
much fun doing it
i um i really learned a lot about the
genre like there's a different way to
shoot it there's a different way to
direct it i mean it's all kind of it was
really informative i i super enjoyed it
well it was very entertaining to watch
um you know obviously these two women
want to be country stars they they go
and meet their you know musical idol for
you who is someone that you would love
to meet someone that you would travel to
and see them in their abandon-ish
mansion and potentially risk your life
for
i'm not sure i would do that for anybody
good answer good answer
i don't have a lot of illusion you know
these are two girls that will go to any
lengths two a two and i i remember being
a young artist and you do have that
mentality of like okay
what do i have to do to get this door
open
so they take a big risk
by heading out there and um
you know when i was younger i might have
done stuff like that now i i have a
better understanding that you know
famous people are just people
so
um
but at their age
you know the movie really touches on you
know
how far you'll go to get famous and
you know
um
harper's character has really
um
sort of uh suffered the
the the perils of being famous and what
that really
does to a person and then she has that
huge secret which was all in the name of
being famous you know absolutely
all that and you know
what what what the movie is about
redemption really that's what i suppose
absolutely um over you know your time in
hollywood is there someone that you met
that you kind of fangirled over that
kind of left you a bit speechless
because you you kind of idolized them
growing up
yeah i'm trying to think you know i just
had a fangirl moment
who was it now i can't even think of who
it was
but you know i grew up here so i don't
and i'm born in you know my parents were
in this so yeah i don't have a lot of
like i i just know this job is being
really you're lucky when you get it and
it's hard work and
you know
um people are people so um i don't have
i don't have a lot of fangirl moments
even though
i can't think of who it was well oh oh i
know who it was
i would be very fan girl over lady gaga
oh
good one
that that's what i would be and and
somebody saw her walking in my
neighborhood and i and i definitely was
like oh my god
if you ever see her again give her a
parking pass
[Laughter]
i think she's really something i i love
that answer and i completely agree with
you um listen i'm sure so many people uh
have
moments when they meet you you've been a
part of so many iconic shows married
with children sons of anarchy futurama
when fans come up to you
which project have you done that they
want to talk to you the most about
it's kind of a mixture it's like a
little bit you know i can always tell
when it's a futurama fan because
they have a certain vibe about them and
they're kind of like sciency people sort
of you know what i mean yeah and um
the sun's fans are deaf well suns fans
range
from everything i mean i remember going
to the drop-off line at my kid's school
and the moms were freaking out about
sons of anarchy so you never quite know
who was watching it and then there's the
die hard married with children you know
what i've been getting a lot of lately i
made a movie
right after married with children called
smart house
okay and if you were of a certain age
like in the second grade or third grade
you are now like in your late 20s early
30s and you love me
smart house yeah yeah okay the disney
movie
it was like i played like the the um it
was about a house that was
technologically
run and i was the voice of the house
oh my god amazing i know it's pretty
amazing because i keep meeting people
lately that are like smart house you're
the smart house mom
oh my gosh well that is going on my list
i'm going to go home watch that tonight
because i i watch everything so i need
to see this um is there a project that
you took on that you had
no idea would take off the way that it
did is there something that really
surprised you
married with children married children
started on the fox network when there
really wasn't a fox network there were
only like five shows
it wasn't in the whole country you had
to put like little rabbit ears on your
tv to get it
and you know it was completely
irreverent and i thought hysterically
funny
it took about three years before we even
realized that people were watching it i
mean it was really so
i had no expectation i don't think any
of us had expectation of it being
successful or let alone affairs
and then became such a staple for so
many people i mean i grew up with that
that was on in my house all the time
wow
it's the best i know thank you parents
for letting me watch that i was gonna
say how old were you i know probably way
too young
nobody
listen so great getting to interview you
congratulations on this movie i want to
see more in the genre you killed it i
know i i would like to do more it was
really fun
you